The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: All right
everyone, let's get started.
So good afternoon.
So this is the 3rd
lecture of 6.0001 and 600.
As always, please
download slides and code
to follow along.
So a quick recap of
what we did last time.
Last time, we talked about
strings as a new object type,
as sequences of characters.
And then we introduced
two new concepts
that allowed us to
write slightly more
complicated programs.
So we introduced branching, with
these keywords, if, elif, else.
And branching allowed
us to write programs
that, us, as programmers,
could introduce decisions
into our programs.
And then we introduced two
different kinds of loops,
while loops and for loops.
And those also added a
little bit of complexity
to our programs.
Today, we're going to talk a
little bit more about strings.
So we're going to see a
couple of more operations
that you can do on strings
and string objects.
And then we're going
to talk about three
different algorithms,
a guess and check
algorithm, an
approximate solution
algorithm, and a bisection
method algorithm.
So let's dive right in.
We'll talk a little bit
about strings, first.
So strings, we thought of them
as sequences of characters,
case sensitive, as we saw in
programs we wrote last lecture.
And strings are objects.
And we can do all of these
operations on string objects,
like test if they're equal, less
than, greater than, and so on.
It turns out, we can do more
than just concatenate two
strings together or do
these little tests on them.
So we're going to start
introducing the idea
of a function or a procedure.
And we're going to see
more about functions
and how you can write your
own functions next lecture.
But for today, you can
think of a function
as sort of a procedure that
does something for you.
Someone already wrote this.
So the first one
we're going to look at
is a pretty popular function.
And when applied on a string,
this function, called len,
will tell you the
length of a string.
So that's going to tell
you how many characters
are in the string.
And characters are going
to be letters, digits,
special characters,
spaces, and so on.
So it's just going to
count how many characters
are in a string.
So if I have the string
s is equal to "abc"--
remember a string is in
quotation marks-- then,
if I do this, if I write
this expression, len s, here,
since it's an expression,
it has a value.
So it evaluates to
a certain value.
And by definition, it's
going to tell me what
the length of the string,
which is 3 characters long.
Another thing that
we can do on strings
is, since they're a
sequence of characters,
I might want to get
what character is
at a certain position.
So we do this using this
fancy word called indexing.
But pretty much what
indexing into a string means
is you're going
to tell Python, I
want to know the character,
at this certain position
or at this certain
index, inside my sting.
So once again, let's use this
string, s is equal to "abc."
And let's index into it.
So in computer science, we start
from 0, counting by convention.
Notice, we had a problem
set 0 in this class.
Python is no different.
So in Python, you start
indexing at position 0.
Or you start indexing at 0.
So the first character, in your
string, we say is at position 0
or at index 0.
The next character in
the string is at index 1.
And the next character in
the string is at index 2.
In Python, it turns
out, you can also
use negative numbers to index.
And if you index into the string
with negative 1, for example,
that means that you want the
last character in the string.
So the last character
in your string
is always going to be
at position negative 1,
the second-to-last
character is at negative 2,
third-to-last character
is at negative 3,
and so on and so on.
So the way you
index into a string
is with these square
brackets, here.
And this is the notation.
So if I want the character
at position 0 or at index 0,
I say s, which is the
string I want to index into.
And then, inside
the square brackets,
I say what index I want.
So s at index 0 is going to
be the value "a." s at index 1
is going to be the value
"b," and so on and so on.
And we can also do
negative indexing, as well.
I added this in here.
If you do try to
index into a string
beyond the limits
of the string--
and we can even
try this out, just
to show you that it's not the
end of the world if we do that.
If we have s is equal to "abc,"
and we have s at position 20,
for example,
obviously, my string
is only length 3, so
what's at position 20?
I get an error.
I call this angry
text, here, in Python.
But really, the most
relevant thing to note
is these last couple
of lines here.
This tells you what
line is problematic.
So s at position
20 has an issue.
And this last line here tells
me what actual error I have.
So it's an index
error, which means
I'm trying to index too
far into the string,
because it only has
three characters.
So it's nice to be able to
get a single character out
of my string.
But sometimes, I might
want to get a substring.
So I want to start at
the first character
and go halfway into
the string, or I
want to take a few
characters in between,
or I want to skip every other
letter or something like that
in my string.
So if I want to do this slightly
more complicated interaction
with strings, we call that
slicing, slicing into a string.
And this notation here should
seem a little bit familiar,
because we saw it last lecture
when we did it with range.
We had a start,
stop, and a step.
The notation was a
little bit different,
because, in range, we had
open-close parentheses
and commas in between.
But except for that, this
sort of works the same.
The start is the
index, starting from 0,
from where you want to
slice into this string.
The stop is the stop index.
So you're going to go
up until stop minus 1
and take that index.
And then the step is how many
letters you wish to take.
So this is the
full notation here.
But sometimes, you
can not give it
a third sort of number in here.
So if you only give
it two numbers,
then, to Python, that represents
just the start and the stop.
And by default, step
is going to be 1.
And there's a lot of other
things you can do with strings.
You can omit numbers and
just leave colons in Python.
By definition, the way
that whoever wrote slicing
had decided, if
you omit numbers,
then it's going to be
equivalent to these things here.
So we slice using square
brackets, just like indexing.
Except now, we can
give it two numbers.
So with this string, s, if
we slice into the string s,
we start from index 3
and go up until index 6.
So if we have abcdefgh, this is
position 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7.
And you just count.
So s, starting from 3 and going
till 6, is going to start here,
3.
So it's going to come
up with-- sorry d.
And then we're going to take e.
And then we're going to take f.
And since we're going
until stop minus 1,
we're not going to take g.
Because this is position 6, and
we're going until 6 minus 1.
The next one here, 3, 6, 2
is going every other one.
So we start at 3, and then
we skip every other one,
so we go d but not e, and
then f, and then stop.
If you do s and then nothing
inside except colons,
notice that you're going
to have s, and then
nothing, and then colon,
nothing, colon, nothing.
So nothing for start, nothing
for stop, nothing for step.
And that's just going to value
it to the string, itself.
It's the same as 0 to the
length s going every step.
This one might
actually be useful.
It reverses the string
automatically for you.
So with this one
little line here,
you can get the
inverse of your string.
And that's equivalent to that.
So the minus 1 represents
starting from the end
and going back every letter.
And then this one's a little
bit more complicated but also
not too bad.
So as we're doing
these string slices,
again, if you're unsure
what something does,
just type it into Spider.
And you might be surprised.
You might not be.
But it's a good way
to check yourself,
to make sure you're
understanding what's happening.
One thing I want to
mention, and it's
good to keep this in
the back of your mind.
We're going to come
back to this as we
start talking about slightly
more complicated object types.
But strings are immutable.
So just keep this word
in the back of your mind
as we go through this class.
And what I mean by this is
that an actual string object,
once it's created,
cannot be modified.
This might not mean
anything right now.
But let me just draw
a little something.
Let's say I have this
string, s is equal to hello.
Remember, in the
first lecture, we
drew a diagram
sort of like this.
This is my memory.
I have this object "hello."
And this object, "hello" is
bound to this variable s.
So now I can access the object
"hello" using this variable s.
Now you might think, well, since
I could index into a string,
I might be able to just say
something like, s at position 0
is equal to y.
And that will just change
the little h into a y,
and I'll have a new object.
Well strings are immutable,
which means, in Python,
you're not actually
allowed to do this.
And it gives you an error
if you do try to do that.
If you want the variable s to
point to the string, Y-E-L-L-O,
you could just say s
is equal to Y-E-L-L-O.
Or you could do string
operations like this.
And this takes the y
and it concatenates it
to the string s,
all of the elements
starting from position
1, which is e, l, l, o.
So this makes Y-E-L-L-O.
Now internally,
what happens when
I write this line
is Python says,
OK, I'm going to break my
bond with this original object
"hello."
I'm going to bind
my string variable
s to the new object "yello."
and this other, old object
still is in memory somewhere.
But it's an entirely different
object that I've created here.
Again, it might not
mean anything right now,
but just keep this in
the back of your mind,
strings are immutable.
So the next thing I
want to talk about
is a little bit of
recap on for loops.
And we're going to see how
we can apply for loops, very
easily, to write very
nice, readable code when
dealing with strings.
So remember that for
loops had a loop variable.
My loop variable being this var,
here, in this particular case.
It can be anything you want.
And this variable, in
this particular case,
iterates over this sequence
of numbers, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So the very first time through
the loop, var has a value of 0.
It does the expressions
in the loop.
As soon as they're done,
var takes the value 1.
It does all the
expressions in the loop.
And then var takes the value
2, and it does that all
the way up until 0, 1, 2.
And the last time it goes around
is with var is equal to 3.
And remember, we said that
we can customize our range
in order to start
from a custom value
to end at a different value
and to skip certain numbers.
So, so far, we've only
been using for loops
over a sequence of numbers.
But actually, for loops are a
lot more powerful than that.
You can use them to iterate
over any sequence of values
not just numbers
but also strings.
So here are two pieces of code,
this one and this one here.
These two pieces of code
both do the exact same thing.
To me, possibly to
you, this one looks
a lot more readable than this
one, just at a first glance.
If I were to read this one,
just using the keywords
and variables here, it would
sound like broken English.
But you could decipher
what I'm trying to say.
For a char in a string s,
if the char is equal to "i"
or a char is equal to "u,"
print "There is an i or a u."
It sounds weird, but
you could probably
tell what I was
trying to do here.
Whereas up here,
it's a little more
complicated to tell
what I'm doing.
You have to sort of think
about it a little bit.
For some index in
this range of numbers,
0 through the
length of the string
s, if s, at position index, is
an "i" or s at position index
is a "u" print, "There
is an i or a u."
Both of these codes just
go through the string s.
And if it encounters a
letter that's an i or a u,
it's just going to print
out this string here.
But this bottom one is
a lot more pythonic.
It's an actual word created
by the Python community.
And it just looks pretty, right?
You can tell what this
code's supposed to do.
Whereas this one is a little
bit harder to decipher.
So that's sort of an
illustration of a for loop
over a sequence of characters.
So char is going to be
a loop variable, still.
And the loop variable,
instead of iterating over
a set of numbers, it's going
to iterate over every character
in s, directly.
And char is going
to be a character.
It's going to be a letter.
So here's a more
complicated example.
I wrote this code a
couple of years ago.
And it was my attempt at
creating robot cheerleaders ,
because I needed
some motivation.
And then I googled, last
night, "robot cheerleaders,"
and was not disappointed.
Created this GIF.
It looks pretty cool.
And it looks like they
kind of stole my idea.
But that's fine.
So let's look at what this
code's supposed to do.
I'm going to run it.
I'm going to run it, and
then we'll go through it.
All right, it prints out,
"I will cheer for you!
Enter a word."
You know what, I like robots,
so I'll put in "ROBOTS."
How enthusiastic
am I about robots?
Let's say 6.
So what this is going to
print is-- it's a cheerleader,
right? "Give me an r, r." "Give
me an o, o." "Give me a b, b,"
and so on and so on.
"What does that spell?
ROBOTS."
And it's going to print it 6
times, because I'm 6 out of 10
enthusiastic about robots.
So that's pretty much what
that code's supposed to do.
And you can write it using
what we've learned so far.
Now let's go through
it a little bit.
And I'm going to show
you just how easy it
is to convert this code using
a for loop over characters.
Right now, what it does is
it asks the user for input,
so a word and a number.
And then it does this
thing, here, right?
First, it uses a while loop.
And second, it uses indexing.
And what tips you off
that it's using indexing
is it's using the square
bracket, here, into the word.
And obviously, it's
using a while loop.
And it has to first create
a counter, initialize it.
And then, down here, it's
going to increment it
inside the while loop.
If you remember,
that's sort of what
we need to do for while loops.
So it's going to start at 0,
and it's just basically going
to go through index i is
equal to 0, 1, 2, 3 4, which
is going to go all the way to
the end of the word, whatever
the user typed in, in
this case "ROBOTS."
It's going to get the
character at that position.
word at position i is
going to be a character.
This line here is just for the
cheerleading to make sense.
It's just to take
care of letters that
make sense to use an, right?
So give me a b, give me an b.
So give me an b does
not make sense, right?
So that's just
taking care of that.
And I'm using this
in keyword to check
whether the character-- so
the character, r, for example,
in robots-- is
inside an letters.
And an letters I've defined
up here, which is these
are all the letters
that make sense
to put an an before the letter.
So give me an r for
example, here, on the right.
And so if it makes sense to
use an before the letter,
use that, and otherwise
use just an a.
And after I'm done, I say,
"What does that spell?"
And then it's just a for loop
that goes times many times
and prints out the word
and the exclamation mark.
So this code might have been
a little bit more intuitive
if I rewrote it or
if I'd originally
written it with a for loop.
So this part here, the
while loop and indexing
and creating my
original counter,
we can get rid of that.
And we can replace it with
this, for char in word.
I'm originally using
char, so I can use char
as my loop variable again.
And simply, I'm just going to
iterate over the word, itself.
So now, instead of
having this mess here, I
have a one-liner that says,
for every character in my word,
do all this stuff here.
So that remains the same.
And then I don't even need to
increment a counter variable,
because I'm not using
while loops anymore.
I'm just using a for loop.
So the code becomes-- delete
that-- for char in word.
And then delete that.
And that does the
exact same thing.
And it's a lot more readable.
So this was our toolbox at
the beginning of this course.
We are two and half,
I guess, lectures in.
These are the things
we've added to it.
We know integer,
floats, Booleans.
We know a bit of string
manipulation, math operations.
We added, recently, these
conditionals and branching
to write slightly more
interesting programs.
And now we have loops,
for and while loops
to add interesting and
more complicated programs.
So with these, the second
part of this lecture
is going to be looking at
three different algorithms.
That's the sort of
computer science part
of this class, Introduction
to Computer Science
and Programming using Python.
Don't let the word
algorithm scare you.
They're not that complicated.
You just have to sort of
think a little bit about them.
And you'll be able to get them.
So we're going to look
at three algorithms, all
in the context of solving
one problem, which
is finding the cube root.
The first algorithm
is guess and check,
then we're going to look at
an approximation algorithm,
and then a bisection search.
So the first is the
guess and check method.
You might have done this,
in math, in high school.
The guess and check method
is also sometimes called
exhaustive enumeration.
And you'll see why.
So given a problem, let's say,
find the cube root of a number,
let's say you can guess a
starting value for a solution.
The guess and check
method works if you're
able to check if your
solution is correct.
So if your guess is
originally 0, you can say,
is 0 cubed equal to the
cube of whatever I'm trying
to find the cube root of?
So if I'm trying to
find the cube root of 8,
is 0 cubed equal to 8?
No.
So the solution is not correct.
If it's not correct,
guess another value.
Do it systematically
until you find a solution
or you've guessed all
the possible values,
you've exhausted all
of your search space.
So here's a very simple guess
and check code that finds
the cube root of a number.
So I'm trying to find
the cube root of 8.
So my cube is 8.
I'm going to have a
for loop that says,
I'm going to start from 0.
And I'm going to go
all the way up to--
So I'm going to start from 0
and go all the way up to 8.
For every one of these
numbers, I'm going to say,
is my guess to the power
of 3 equal to the cube 8?
And if it is, I'm going
to print out this message.
Pretty simple, however, this
code is not very user friendly,
right?
If the user wants to
find the cube root of 9,
they're not going to get
any output, because we never
print anything in
the case of the guess
not being a perfect cube.
or the cube not
being a perfect cube.
So we can modify the
code a little bit
to add two extra features.
The first is we're
going to be able to deal
with negative cubes,
which is kind of cool.
And the second is we're
going to tell the user,
if the cube is not
a perfect cube,
hey, this cube is
not a perfect cube.
So we're not going to
silently just fail,
because then the user
has some sort of feedback
on their input.
So let's step through this code.
We have, first of all, a
for loop just like before.
And we're going to go
through 0 to 8 in this case.
We're using the absolute
value, because we
might want to find the cube
root of negative numbers.
First thing we're doing
is doing this check here.
Instead of guessing whether
the guess to the power of 3
is equal to the
cube, we're going
to check if it's
greater or equal to,
and we're going to do that
for the following reason.
So if we're trying to
find the cube root of 8,
for example, versus a
cube root of 9-- this is 8
and this is 9-- what is
this code going to do?
It's going to first guess 0.
0 cubed is not
greater or equal to 8.
1 cubed is not
2 cubed is greater
or equal to 8,
so here, once we've guessed
2, we're going to break.
Because we found a
number that works.
And there's no need
to keep looking.
Once we've found the cubed
root of this number 8,
there's no need to keep
searching the remainder, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8.
Sort of the same idea
when we're trying
to find the cube root of 9.
We're going to start with 0.
0 to the power of
3 is less than 9.
1 to the power of 3 is less 9.
2 to the power of
3 is less than 9.
When we get to 3
to the power of 3,
that's going to
be greater than 9.
So this code tells
us, once we've
picked a number that's
beyond the reasonable number
of our cubed root, of our cube,
the cubed root of our cube,
then we should stop.
Because, again, it doesn't
make sense to keep searching.
Because if 3 to the power of
3 is already greater than 9,
4 to the power of 3 is also
going to be greater than 9
and so on.
So once we break here, we
either have guess being 2
or guess being 3 depending on
what cube we're trying to find.
And if the guess to the power
or 3 is not equal to the cube,
then, obviously, the cube
was not a perfect cube.
So that's this case
here, if we were looking
at at the cube root of 9.
And otherwise, this
part here just looks
at whether we should make it
a positive or a negative cube.
So if our original cube
was less than 0, then,
obviously, the cube root
of a negative number
is going to be a
negative number,
and, otherwise,
it's just our guess.
So that's the guess
and check method,
slightly more
feature-rich program
for guessing the cube root.
But that only tells us the
cube root of perfect cubes
and doesn't really give
us anything else, any more
information.
So sometimes, you might
want to say, well,
I don't care that 9
is not a perfect cube,
just give me a
close enough answer.
So that's where approximate
solutions come in.
So this is where we're OK with
having a good enough solution.
So in order to do
that, we're going
to start with a guess
and then increment that
guess by some small value.
Start from 0 and start
incrementing by 0.001
and just go upwards from there.
And at some point, you might
find a good enough solution.
In this program, we're going to
keep guessing as long as we're
not close enough.
And close enough is going
to be given by this epsilon
value in the program.
So as long as the guess cubed
minus the cube-- so how far
away are we from
the actual answer--
is greater than some
epsilon, keep guessing,
because the solution
is not good enough.
But once this is
less than epsilon,
then we've reached a
good enough solution.
So two things to note with
approximate solutions.
So you can get more
accurate answers
if your step size is
really, really small.
If you're incrementing
by 0.0001,
you're going to get a really
good approximate solution,
but your program
will be a lot slower.
Same sort of idea with epsilon,
you can change epsilon.
If you change epsilon
to be a bigger epsilon,
you're sacrificing
accuracy, but you're
going to reach a
solution a lot faster.
So here's the code for the
approximate solution of a cube
root.
It might look
intimidating, but, look,
almost half this code is
just initializing variables.
So we're initializing,
this is the cube
we want to find
the cube root of.
We pick an epsilon of this.
We start with a guess of 0.
We start with an
increment of 0.0001.
And just for fun, let's keep
track of the number of guesses
that it takes us to
get to the answer.
This is similar to the
guess and check from before.
It's not similar.
Well this part is similar to
the guess and check from before.
So we're going to take the
guess to the power of 3
minus the cube, right?
So that's how far away are
we from the actual answer?
And we're going to
say, if that's not good
enough-- so if
we're still greater
than or equal to the
epsilon-- then keep guessing.
So we're going to be
stuck in this loop, where
we keep guessing
values, until we've
reached a guess
that's good enough,
so until we're
less than epsilon.
And way we keep guessing
is just with this line,
right here, which says,
increment my guess
by increment, and increment
being this really small value.
That make sense?
So I'm going to
keep incrementing
my guess by that small value.
Before I go on, I'm
going to run the code.
And we're going to discover
a small issue with it.
So with 27, we're
going to run it.
Perfect, it took me 300 guesses.
But 2.99999 is close
to the cube root of 27.
We can find the cube
root of this guy here.
And it took me 20,000
guesses, but I figured out
that 200.99999, so 201,
is close to the cube
root of that large number.
I should have done this.
This is going to be
a giveaway, you guys.
Sorry.
Then we're going
to have-- let's say
I want to try cube of 10,000.
So 10,000 is not a perfect cube.
So we can run the code.
And with 8,120,601 I had
already gotten an answer.
But with 10,000, I'm not
getting an answer yet, right?
So I'm thinking that there
might be something wrong.
So I'm going to stop my code.
So I just hit Control C,
because I feel like I've
entered an infinite loop.
And, in fact, I have.
So what ended up happening
is this problem here.
So I'm going to draw something.
According to the code,
I'm going to start from 0,
and I'm going to increment
my guesses, like that.
With every little increment,
I'm going to make a new guess.
I'm going to take that
guess to the power of 3.
I'm going to subtract
the cube, and I'm
going to figure out if
I'm less than epsilon.
This is the epsilon that I want
to be in, this little bit here.
So with every new
guess, I might be,
maybe-- so this is
where I want to be,
within this little
boundary here.
With every new guess,
I might be here.
With the next guess, over
here, I might be here.
When I make another
guess, I might be here.
So I'm getting close to
being within epsilon.
But maybe with my
next guess, I'm
going to hop over my epsilon and
have made too big of a guess.
So just because of
the way the numbers
were chosen in this example,
just to illustrate this,
using an increment of 0.01, a
with finding the cube of 10,000
and epsilon of 0.1, it
turns out that, as I'm
doing all these
calculations, I'm
going to skip over this perfect
sort of epsilon difference.
So first, I'm going
to be too small.
And then I'm going
to be too large.
And once I've become too large
or too far away from epsilon,
the guesses I continue
to make are just
going to be even farther
away from epsilon.
And I'm not going
to get to my answer.
And that's why I've reached
an infinite loop in this code.
All I'm doing in
this code is checking
whether my guess cube minus
cube is less than epsilon.
The only thing I
need to do here is
sort of add this
little clause, here,
that says, oh, by the way, also
check that I'm less than cube.
Because this is just like we
did in the very first program,
when I'm checking 0,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
when I'm trying to find
the cube root of 8.
Once I've reached 8,
I'm going to stop.
And it's the same thing here.
So I just added
this little clause
that says, well,
while I'm greater
than or equal to
epsilon and I'm still
less than the actual
cube, just keep searching.
But once I've reached the
cube, then stop searching.
And with 10,000,
you can see that I
failed to actually find-- so
that's what this part, here,
does.
It tells me I've
failed to find the cube
root with those
particular parameters.
The last thing we're going to
look at is bisection search.
And to illustrate this, I'm
going to need one volunteer.
And you're going to
play a game with me
in front of the whole class.
And there will be a prize.
There go the hands.
In the blue shirt, right there.
Cool.
So the prize is going
to be, once again, this.
I promise I don't have millions
of these, Google glasses.
I also don't work for Google.
I just happened to get a couple.
So the game is this.
I'm going to ask you to pick
a number, a whole number,
between 0 and 100.
And I'm going to
try to guess it.
And you need to
make it hard for me.
And you need to make it so hard
for me that I cannot guess it
within 10 guesses.
And if you can do that, if
I cannot guess it within 10
guesses, you get this.
And I'm going to draw out
what I do as we go along.
So do you have your number?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANA BELL: Perfect.
Let me erase that.
Actually, I should've
probably kept that,
because I'll still use it.
There's the numbers, 0 to 100.
Is your number 50?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANA BELL: 50 Was my guess.
So I've made one guess.
Is your number higher
or lower than 50?
AUDIENCE: Higher.
ANA BELL: Higher.
Is your number-- my next
guess is going to be 75.
And the reason I'm guessing 75
is because-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Sophie.
ANA BELL: What's that?
ANA BELL: Sophie.
Sophie said, 50 was too low.
So I immediately know that it
cannot be any less than 50.
So I've already eliminated
half of the numbers.
So my next guess is 75.
Is your number 75?
Is your number lower or higher?
AUDIENCE: Higher.
ANA BELL: Since it's higher,
I'm eliminating this half here.
Is your number-- so
between 75 and 100.
Oh, boy, you're
putting me on the spot.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: 87.
ANA BELL: 87, thank you.
87?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANA BELL: Higher or lower?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
ANA BELL: Lower.
So since it's lower, I'm
eliminating that half.
Is your number 81?
Higher or lower?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
ANA BELL: So she said, lower,
so I'm eliminating that half.
Is your number 78?
Oh, boy, that's really hard.
78, OK.
Higher or lower?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
ANA BELL: Is your number 76?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANA BELL: Yay.
All right, perfect,
76 was the number.
So how many guesses have I made?
One, two, three, four, five,
six-- I made six guesses.
So I did get it under 10.
But you know what?
The game was rigged.
So you get the prize anyway,
just because I rigged the game.
Here you go.
Pass it down.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANA BELL: Thank you.
So notice, in bisection
search, what I did was I
eliminated half the search
space with every guess.
I said, well, she said
it's higher or lower,
so I definitely cannot be in
the other search space, right?
If I was doing approximate
solution or, in this case,
guess and check, I would be
asking Sophie, is your number
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, and so on?
So with guess and check,
it would have taken me
76 guesses to get to the number,
whereas, with this bisection
search, that I just
did, it only took me 6.
Isn't that cool?
So that means that the
larger the space actually
is, that I need to
search, the better it
is to use bisection search,
this bisection search method.
So that's basically what
I'm illustrating here.
So we have our
original search space.
We're going to choose a
guess halfway, eliminate
half of the guesses.
Then we're going look in
the remaining interval,
eliminate half the guesses,
and so on and so on.
So then this is the code
for bisection search.
Also looks intimidating,
but it's not so bad.
So we're initializing a
bunch of stuff up here.
The most important couple
of things we're initializing
are, first of all, this high
and this low boundaries.
So with the guessing game,
the low boundary was 0,
and the high boundary was 100.
When we're looking
at the cube root,
the low boundary
is going to be 0,
and the high boundary is
going to be just my cube,
because a guess to the power
of 3 cannot be any greater than
cube.
And then, I'm just going
to do the same procedure
that I did with the
guessing game, which
is I'm going to make my
guess, be halfway in between.
So with this guessing game,
I had to sort of choose,
if there were four
numbers in between,
should I go higher or lower?
Well, when we're doing
by bisection search,
here, we don't care about that.
We're just going to do
floating point division,
because we want decimal numbers.
So I have a low boundary
and a high boundary.
And I figured out
my halfway point.
Then I have this
while loop here.
A while loop is similar to the
approximation method, where,
as long as I don't have a
guest that's good enough--
so this, depicted by
this greater or equal
to epsilon-- as long as my
guess is not good enough,
I'm going to keep guessing.
That's what this
while loop is saying.
So if the guess to the
power of 3 minus cube
is not good enough,
keep guessing.
And the way I keep guessing
is this part, here,
says, my guess was too low.
So if my guess was too
low, set the low boundary
to be the guess.
Because I don't care about
all of the other numbers
that are much lower than me.
So set the low to be the guess.
That's what that line is doing.
And otherwise, my
guess was too high.
That's what this else is doing.
So set the high to be
the guess, because I
don't care about numbers
any higher than my guess.
Once I have these
new boundaries,
I make another
guess, again, halfway
in between the new
boundary points.
So essentially, I'm
just halving my interval
with every single guess.
And that's what the
while loop is doing.
And then I print out
the remaining part.
So notice the search
space originally being N,
we're halving it
with each guess.
So the first guess
divides it by 2,
the second guess divides
it by 4, and so on.
So by the time we get
to the k-th guess,
N/2k, the k-th guess, let's say
that's the actual answer we're
interested in.
There's only one value
in that little interval.
And that's the answer we want.
So 2 to the k is
equal to N. And then
how many guesses did we make?
k is equal to log
base 2 of N. So when
we are playing the guessing
game of 100, my end was 100.
Log base 2 of 100 is
6.-something, I think.
So in fact, I could
have said, if I
don't guess it
within seven guesses,
you would have won as well.
So that's why the
game was rigged.
So the guess,
notice, it converges
on the order of
log base N instead
of just linearly in terms of N.
So that's why it's so powerful.
One last thing I
want to mention is
the code I showed only
works for positive cubes.
And that's because
of the following.
So I have this 0 and 1.
Let's say I'm trying to
find the cube root of 0.5.
When I first set my initial
boundaries, my low is this one,
and my high is this one.
But what's the cube root of 0.5?
Is it within this boundary or
is it outside this boundary?
AUDIENCE: Outside the boundary.
ANA BELL: I heard, outside.
It's like 0.7 something.
So it's out here.
So with this
particular code, I'm
going to be halving my interval
in between those numbers,
but I'll never get to an answer.
Because the actual cube root
of 0.5, or numbers less than 1,
is going to be
outside that boundary.
So there's a small change you
can make to the program, which
will fix that.
And that's in the code.
I didn't put it in, but it's a
very small change, a small if
statement.
So that's it.
All right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]